hello graham it's chris tarot here from
who wants to be
a millionaire uh so first up
uh let's play who wants to be a
[Applause]
[Music]
billionaire
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
from ireland you're a tv radio presenter
uh writer a novelist i believe i know
raccoon tour it says here so uh let's
have no more delay and
the first question
how many soviets did william shakespeare
write now that's solid stop plays solids
how many soddets did win
right is it
a 62 b
84 c 112
or d 154
uh shakespeare i'm not very good on
shakespeare is there any chance can i
use my
phone or friend you've got your lifeline
you've got your lifeless grave you've
got your uh ask the audience which i
wouldn't try
i'm not going to ask the audience you've
got your 50 50 uh or you've got your
phone a friend
i do i'll phone a friend uh now people
who know shakespeare
uh now we've either got ian mckellen or
judy dench i'm going with
judy dench here we go
put on speaker speaker
is it we don't know
she better be hello
sorry i'm not here at the moment to take
your call but if you'd be kind enough
just to leave a
name and hello hello judy dench how
hello it's graham norton here very very
nice to hear you
and how are you coping uh judy dench
well you know
um day to day doing a bit of this and
that
must be this
uh i'm just kind of uh thinking
waking up and again what can i do today
okay well what i'm doing
for no good reason is playing who wants
to be a millionaire you're very bold
so i've got a question here's the
question okay
so the question is how many sonnets did
shakespeare write i'll give you the
answer straight away because
that's what i'm trying to do is learn
the sonnets it's 154
graham how many have you learned
about six
i've got a bit i'm i'm planning on
having quite a lot to do
so you are certain it's 154.
yes it's it's 154. all right thank you
so much judy uh
good luck oh thank you so much i good
luck to you in the in the restaurant and
we'll see you in the flesh
very soon i hope hopefully all right
much love bye-bye bye-bye
uh okay she sounds very confident uh so
i am going to go with d
154. that's the answer you go for group
yes
for a billion pounds
it's the correct answer 154 well done
graham
amazing well done lockdown it's
stressful for everyone but
you know children it's particularly hard
because you can't really explain it to
them or anything
but you're doing a lovely thing with
meditation
especially for kids yeah we uh this
health and wellness fitness app
we brought out a couple of years ago um
has meditations for adults and
a friend of ours said why don't you try
these meditations for your kids and i
thought that's
not gonna work uh you know my kids can't
sit still that long
and we started doing it and it was
fantastic and even the sort of sleep
visualizations and
positive thinking and so on and so um i
recorded a few
the children's meditations on our app
and as did taka waititi
who uh directed for ragnarok and jojo
rabbit um
and uh yeah so and people are loving it
it's it's it's uh yeah
again you see you say they're for
children judging from twitter i think
other people are enjoying them uh here's
a lady
this is definitely more from mommy than
baby
this one chris hemsworth guided
meditations on center thinly veiled
four kids you're welcome that is all
and this lady listen to consensus
meditation app with the kids now mommy
just needs to pop off for some alone
time
hashtag thor hashtag four and i have to
say chris
like when you listen to this i do get
what they mean here's a little clip of
you
uh helping the meditation
hi everybody
[Music]
are you all tucked up in bed feeling
warm and comfortable
and take a few big breaths into your
belly
and each time you breathe out feel your
body go
soft and wobbly like jelly
thank you for that chris thanks that
moment of zen
it's beautiful your music videos your
fans always love them but the last one
in particular for never worn white this
is where you
uh revealed your your baby bump for the
first time
[Music]
oh i mean you must have known you were
going to cause a sensation with that
and to be honest that was really early
on so i think half of that was taco bell
but uh yeah i mean i thought okay what
better way
to you know release big information
big news in my own life especially to my
fans who've been following me since i
was
almost a teenager really and um
grown up with me it's kind of like where
we've been on this journey together
i thought do it via music yeah
well to say your fans were happy for you
is an understatement
we've got some clips of fans who filmed
themselves
uh seeing the baby bump for the first
time here we go
okay am i am i off she's holding her
tummy
is she pregnant is she pregnant
is she don't believe me
oh my god
she's pregnant
okay that's so cute
oh she's gonna be such a beautiful
mother
mother she's holding a
belly
no i'm the middle one was excited
because he was in a womb so recently
yes yes these are all very young
children
actually i think we've got one more fan
clip
oh my god this isn't just a fan that's
alan carr
do you know what alanis is a lovely baby
name
for a girl alanis oh it sounds like
that's been taken babe sorry
oh my god i
oh well i am a fan and congratulations
my love
thanks babes something we've been doing
will is
talk we're talking to actors uh from
their own homes we're just seeing
you know anything they've nicked from
film sets let's call it
memorabilia yeah do you have you got
anything
good at hand oh i've got a couple things
i've got uh
i hope you can see it this first item is
my my
channel 4 news ring from anchorman
which is uh yes ron burgundy wore this
on every day of filming which is a
classic and then
i have one other item which
which is in a special cardboard box here
and these are my uh prosthetic testicles
from step right
very lifelike and uh
i have brought these out um much to the
horror
at many a dinner party i presented these
so uh yeah these these fake testicles
were what were put on uh
brennan's drum kit dale's from there's
going to be a screen grab of that that's
going to go viral
but there's some bollocks in your face
as i watch the series though jeff i was
struck that in most episodes
you seem to get a lot of free stuff well
no you may have gotten the misimpression
that's not what i'm
in it for uh and on this show i got some
nice stuff but only a couple of things
but they were very nice in that episode
where i visited uh detroit bikes
on our episode about bicycles they made
me a bicycle i didn't have an adult
bicycle as i tell them
i have in my backyard and i ride with my
two sons
i love that and then oh oh
i forgot to get i'm going to run away
because i forgot
i i was going to show you something that
i got from this
where i visited it i'll go get it i'll
do it i'll be right back okay
don't okay don't look at it i'll check
emails production designed shelves
behind this but i'll be right i'll be
right back
okay okay
here i come here i come
yeah yeah i'm so sorry
i had we had uh cooked this up but i
forgot i put it in my closet
i there was an episode on jewelry we
went to
johnny dang's place who does a lot of
things for uh sports
stars and hip-hop artists and he made me
a grill you know what a grill is a grill
for you
is it for your mouth yeah it's cheap
i'll put it i'll show you
both sets oh jack
[Laughter]
and that kind of chemistry between the
two of you between johnny comer plays
villanelle
and yourself i mean did you know that
was going to be there
or does it develop is that just good
acting what's the story
um you know all those three things
you're saying did you know
did it develop and is a good acting i
think it's all three things can i just
say
i'm so impressed you were listening to
what i was saying i'm hardly listening
to myself
i was like wow sandra listen to the
question
i do very very impressive i really i
tried to and so those three points it's
like when i first met jody and we
had our first kind of chemistry read
together i knew that we had
good chemistry i could just tell because
it was actually
speaking about listening it was i could
it was the way that we were listening
together
and the way that i could hear and i it's
only so much i could hear i could
feel how she was receiving anything that
i was
moving giving to her and that she would
react and i
i do think chemistry in some ways
between
actors is about listening so i think
it's to have that skill as well
sorry oh yeah i was listening
i was listening it's like i i set you up
and you just nice that's good listen
if you want to give us a preview of
solid 27 or is there
is there a particular favorite you have
that you'd like to
brighten our evening with well you know
there is one here and it's one that i
have
recorded i hope you will not feel that
you were second choice in this
no no no i'll give you a few lines of
this one because it's one of my
favorites
by the way there are 154 sonics and most
of them i don't know at all
so you know um judy dench is spending
lockdown
learning them she's learning them i mean
she's only got to six
but that's her plan
and does she then perform them no i
don't know what she does with them i
mean
annoys the neighbors i don't know what
she does it's just an
exercise okay well this is sonnet 17.
who will believe my verse in time to
come
if it were filled with your most high
deserts
though yet heaven knows it is but as a
tomb
which hides your life and shows not half
your parts
if i could write the beauty of your
eyes and in fresh numbers
number all your graces the age to come
would
say this poet lies such heavenly touches
never touched earthly faces so should my
papers yellowed with their
age be scorned like old men of less
truth than tongue and your true rights
be termed a poet's
rage and stretch it meter of an antique
song
but were some child of yours alive
that time you should live twice
in it and in my rhyme
thank you beautiful uh
thank you so much patrick thank you
sonny i'll let you lovebirds get off
now i've got a picture of you at the
oscars the night of the oscars
and so this diamond oh my god i look
i look just like that right now it's so
weird it's uncanny
but that is the diamond that diamond is
in the middle of that breakfast at
tiffany's
yeah so that diamond was in a necklace
that audrey wore
for press for breakfast at tiffany's and
then the diamond was
put into a different setting and it's
it's this priceless diamond that
tiffany's had and they
they offered it to me to wear at the
oscars and i was you know
the street kid in me from new york was
like hell yeah i'm gonna wear that big
thing
but does it not gonna wreck your knight
because presumably you've got security
guards
under each armpit and there's like
there's people crawling all over them
i already thought i had too much
security before i put that diamond on
and then i put that diamond on and i was
like am i the president
like i didn't really know what was going
on and it it was really funny because i
really didn't know
what was gonna happen that night i was
just excited to be there you know that's
mostly generally how i feel at these
events is like oh i'm just happy to be
here
right and so then i won
an oscar and i was so excited and i'm
having champagne
and i'm drinking my sister was my date
so you know like we're really barreling
through
the champagne backstage with the oscar
and i just
leave and i i leave with the diamond on
and i i didn't tell anyone like i just
left
and tiffany started freaking out they
were like
she's gone she she left with the diamond
and actually
i went to go hang out with madonna at
her manager's house
and i got to the house and i was i was
just chilling with madonna while like
all these
security guards were like just side
eyeing me
from you know every corner of the room
and every time i hugged someone they
they would like like get a little closer
to make sure it was still on
and then and then i left and i really
wanted to go to taco bell so we were
trying to go to taco bell and then all
of a sudden the car got pulled over
by tiffany's security and it was very
politely moved removed from my neck
you